just to give a few examples and I stress
again they're misleading because they're
few take say the question of freedom of
press
that's a picket because it's obviously a
matter that the press is naturally much
concerned about and in fact the press
has been very much concerned about
freedom of the press and the last deck
let's just keep for the last decade in
the last decade there's been plenty of
material in the press about freedom of
the press mainly in Latin America and
ask your friends to name one newspaper
in Latin America that has raised freedom
of press issues which newspaper in Latin
America has been suppressed unfairly by
a state and therefore we have to defend
it well you know 99 people out of a
hundred will name la prensa in Nicaragua
and the reason they'll name it is
because there have been massive coverage
of the tribulations of La Prensa and
Nicaragua there was a study by in
Harper's Magazine by Francisco Goldman a
media analyst who found that the New
York Times alone was giving something
like 5 references a month that's more
than one a week to the tribulations of
LA prensa and Nicaragua that's probably
more coverage than all freedom of the
press issues throughout the rest of the
world combined probably much more in
fact well that's an interesting choice
we can take a look at it not not only
coverage but also enthusiastic support I
mean Lee for example in in 1986 in June
1986 there was a interesting series of
events the World Court condemned the
United States for its unlawful use of
force and violation of treaties in its
war against Nicaragua and called upon
the United States to desist from these
crimes Congress responded to this by
voting a hundred million dollars in aid
to increase to accelerate the unlawful
use of force the Reagan administration
announced that this is for real this is
a real war
and there was enthusiastic coverage of
that the world Court decision was simply
dismissed as an annoying bit of nonsense
either ignored or falsified but anyway
dismissed it's the court that was the
criminal not the United States and the
in response to this virtual declaration
of war as the Reagan administration
described that the Nicaraguan government
suspended La Prensa and that led the
virtual hysteria in the United States
the Neiman fellows that journalism
fellows at Harvard off immediately gave
the owner of La Prensa Violeta Chamorro
an award the Washington Post had a big
editorial saying she deserves 10 Awards
no that's a newspaper of Valor and that
was the head of the that was the heading
the Murray Kempton left liberal
columnist in the New York Review issued
a plea to people to provide funds for La
Prensa to keep its equipment going that
those funds could be added to the rather
substantial CIA subvention till the
prints ever since 1979 and on well what
is La Prensa the prints has an
interesting newspapers probably unique
in history it's often believed that La
Prensa is the newspaper that
courageously opposed this the Somoza
dictatorship and if you read the press
that's what you would believe well it
does have the same name as that
newspaper but that's about where it ends
in 1980 the right after this ended mr.
revolution the owners of La Prensa fired
the editor and 80% of the staff left
with him because the staff and the
editor refused to support their Pro
contra policy now the editor and the
staff formed another newspaper on the
wave of the audio and if a newspaper is
constituted of its editor and its staff
that's the old La Prensa if a newspaper
is constituted of the money that's
behind it well of course the new the
print says the old la Princesse you just
decide how to decide know what a
newspaper is is it the staff and the
editor or is it the owners and the
equipment this you'll never read about
but it's a fact now the new
Prensa supports the overthrow of the
government by foreign power and does it
quite openly and it's funded by the
foreign power that is trying to
overthrow the government now that's
pretty unusual in fact I can't think of
any remote parallel in history of the
Western democracies so for example
during the Second World War
England did not permit Nazi Germany to
putt to fund and run a major newspaper
in London and the United States did not
permit Japan say to dominate you know to
invest in and run a major newspaper
coming out of New York in fact I mean if
you go that far England and the United
States imposed harsh censorship they
wouldn't even let tiny little dissident
newspapers go through the mails or a
pier and so on there's no power there's
no remote parallel in Western history to
this as far as I can see this
incidentally is never mentioned in media
commentary well nevertheless a true
civil libertarian will defend La Prensa
from harassment even though this is
unique in human history this fact
because of you're a real civil
libertarian you think that the United
States should have allowed Japan and
Germany to dominate the American media
during the Second World War
if you're a real civil libertarian but
we now ask man that we now make the
obvious question I mean we asked whether
the you know the great excitement
virtual hysteria of American
intellectuals over La Prensa is reflects
their libertarian passions or whether
it's because they believe or whether
it's because they're serving power as a
propaganda model predicts that's a fair
question and there's a test there's an
obvious test and we all know how to
apply it it's a test that we apply all
the time when we look at our enemies so
for example suppose you take a look at
the productions of the East German Peace
group or the world peace cannot so which
is sort of communist front organization
you read their publicity there and
you'll see that they have a lot of
criticisms of the United States often
very valid criticisms in fact their
critical discussion of repression in the
United States and in u.s.
Dependencies not only is often valid but
it's often the kind of thing that's not
reported here well do we honor them for
that no of course not we regard them
with contempt and the reason is because
we apply a very simple and obvious test
we ask what do they say about the
repression and atrocities for which
they're responsible
well they say about Soviet repression
and atrocities and as soon as we find
out the answer to that question we just
simply dismiss them with contempt
rightly you begin by talking about your
own responsibility and then sort of you
know on a footnote somewhere you can
talk about the bad things done by other
guys at least if you regard yourself as
a moral agent you know somebody worthy
of minimal respect and attention we
understand that in the case of our
enemies and we might have enough honesty
to apply the same tests to ourselves so
let's try it we can now apply the test
we have this tremendous libertarian
passion over La Prensa the first
newspaper in history to be funded by a
foreign power calling for the overthrow
of the government in which it appears in
which it's published and remember this
is not a major power it's not like the
United States which was never under
threat during the second world war this
is a poor third world country which is
barely able to survive the attack of the
superpower so that we have that and we
can ask how the same press has reacted
to other examples of repression during
the same period in fact in the same area
well there are test cases so let's try a
few let's take out Salvador right nearby
except the US client there once was an
independent press in El Salvador two
small newspapers electronica and Elliott
Independiente two small newspapers they
were not supported by a foreign power
trying to overthrow the government they
were not particularly left-wing they
were independent run by businessmen they
sort of challenged the distribution of
power you know they said maybe we should
have some land reform or something like
that well they're not around anymore
they're not around because the
government that we armed fun train and
support sent its security forces to
destroy them one newspaper was
eliminated by the simple device of
taking an editor and a photojournalist
who were in a son Salvador restaurant
taking them out security forces went in
took them out
so I'd cut him to pieces with machetes
and left them in a ditch at that point
the owner fled and that took care of one
newspaper the second newspaper that
little harder took several bombings
three assassination attempts on the
editor
finally the army surrounded the premises
with tanks and then broke in and smashed
the place up and destroyed it they had
previously a machine-gunning attack had
killed a newsboy at that point the
editor fled that took care of the second
newspaper
well that was eight years ago so we can
now ask how much attention did that
receive that's an example of a violation
of freedom of the press a little more
severe than the harassment of La Prensa
well it wasn't answer to that you can
check the New York Times for example it
has never received one word of mention
in the New York Times news columns it
has never received one editorial
mentioned in all of these years and the
same is true the other media it simply
doesn't matter
these are atrocities committed by our
clients the guys we pay and train to do
that sort of thing
so all of a sudden they are concerned
for freedom of the press disappears or
let's take another US client in fact the
major US client Israel which receives by
far the major US aid and is again not a
small country under attack by a
superpower
well here here to history has set up
some interesting tests the same at
exactly the same time that Nicaragua
suspended La Prensa after the virtual
declaration of war in violation of the
World Court proceedings at the very same
time Israel closed down closed down
permanently to Jerusalem newspapers Arab
newspapers of course closed down to
Jerusalem newspapers on the charge that
the security forces had claimed that
they were supported by a terrorist group
by a hostile group well that went all
the way to the Supreme Court and the
Supreme Court judge that that was
legitimate because in it as it explained
in its judgement no state will ever
permit a business no matter how
legitimate it is that's supported by
hostile elements
and although we have freedom of speech
in Israel it does not extend to
activities that might threaten the
security of the state
well how much cover that's much more
severe than what happened in all the
prints okay so how much coverage did
that get well actually that did get one
mention in the u.s. press it was
mentioned in a letter of mine and the
Boston Globe commenting on the hypocrisy
of the Nieman fellows notice that the
they did not give a prize to these
editors in fact that was never even
reported after the Central America Peace
Accords la prensa was opened the week
right at the time it was opened Israel
closed a Nazareth newspaper that's
inside Israel closed a Nazareth
newspaper permanently on grounds that it
had it was supported again by hostile
elements the editor again went to
Supreme Court pleaded that everything
that appeared in the newspaper passed
through a censorship that was
disregarded on the grounds that if the
state says it's supported by hostile
elements that's all that's required you
never need any evidence when the state
comes along and says security reasons
the courts just accepted
they also closed the news office in
Nablus on the grounds that the editor
who would ra bennett who was already in
jail in fact he was in jail for having
alleged not without charge without legal
charge on the claim that he had contact
with hostile elements his wife had been
running a newspapers claimed that she'd
maintained those contacts they closed
the press office well how much coverage
did that get and there in the US press
answered as far as I can find zero in
both cases well I could here's to hear
some real controlled experiments that
history was kind enough to set up for us
I picked the week of the suspension of
the prints on the week of the opening of
La Prensa I picked a case and I'll solve
there just to round it off let's take
our other client state Guatemala and
let's come up to more recent times
Guatemala we the United States
enthusiastically supported a vast
outbreak of terror and violence in
Guatemala in the early 80s the
Reaganites were positively passionate in
their enthusiasm for this maybe a
hundred thousand people were slaughtered
something like
that may be something roughly that
neighborhood however after a sufficient
massacre had been carried out
they had what's called a democratic
election and there supposed to be a
democracy in Guatemala that's what they
tell us well one of the paid during this
period of us-backed slaughter they
didn't have any censorship the problems
of the press were taking care of simply
by murdering journalists about 50
journalists were murdered including you
know television journalists right in the
middle of broadcasts and so on and for
some reason you didn't need any
censorship when that was going on in
fact I was never barely discussed you
find bare mention of it in the press
well after the return of democracy which
we pride ourselves on one of the editors
who had fled and was living in Mexico
decided to return and he opened a small
newspaper about a year ago last February
called la época again it wasn't calling
for the overthrow the government wasn't
supported by a foreign power it was just
a kind of a left liberal journal small
left liberal journal when he came back
to Guatemala there were immediately
death threats from the death squads
which are just adjunct to the security
forces warning him that he was either
gonna be killed or flee he wasn't
allowed to run that newspaper he
nevertheless might ahead and the
newspaper published a couple of issues
and then in July 15 armed men broke into
the offices fire bombed them kidnapped
the night watchman and destroyed the
premises the next day the editor
Brian Barrera held a press conference to
which no one came except some people
from the European press and said that
plainly there's no possibility for a
free expression in Guatemala he then
received another death threat warning
him he better get out of the country
he'd be killed he was taken to the
airport by a European ambassador to make
sure that he could get out alive and he
fled back to Mexico
well how much coverage did that get
answer zero nothing in the New York
Times nothing in the Washington Post
that's just last year now it's not that
they didn't know about it we know
perfectly well that they knew about it
first of all because it was on the
Internet
was on the wires and so on and so forth
but also because they themselves
referred to it obliquely later about a
month later there was an article in The
New York Times on some cultural
conference in Guatemala back in the arts
pages and the correspondent went there
had some remark buried in there about
época the tripping point it just doesn't
matter I mean that's it's not just
harassment and suppression it's it's you
know destruction and physical disruption
and murder but its carried out by our
clients so it doesn't matter well those
are the kinds of things you find when
you look